Speaker 1: I said I was keeping an open mind.
Let's see how CNN handles the Trump town hall.
Maybe they will hold Trump accountable. Maybe
it will be produced in a way that Trump can't
steamroll Kaitlan Collins and tell lies with a
sycophant crowd. And everybody's going to cheer.
And you know, it won't just be Kaitlan Collins
meekly every once in a while trying to fact check,
but unfortunately that's basically what
it was. And we can simultaneously say
Kaitlan Collins offered some token resistance.
She did try to do some fact checking, sometimes
more successfully, sometimes less successfully
in the context of Trump lying uncontrollably,
spreading really dangerous, corrosive lies about
American democracy in front of a crowd where when
they cheered, it was the absolute worst stuff,
the worst of making fun of sexual assault victim
Jean Carroll. Attacking Kaitlan Collins is nasty
over when the crowd cheered or laughed. You knew
Trump was doing the absolute worst stuff. And
so Kaitlan Collins tried, but she couldn't even
remotely control Trump in her defense. Very few
people could. And that's where we have to question
what was the reason for doing this town hall? It's
May of the year before the election. There isn't
even really a serious challenger to Trump yet. I
know DeSantis is in the twenties. DeSantis isn't
running right now. Nikki Haley has no shot. Vivek
Ramaswamy has no shot. So why do a town hall like
this in May of 2023 for the ratings? It's that
simple. Chris Licht taking over CNN and saying,
this is what we're going to do. Trump ignored the
token fact checks he spoke over Kaitlan Collins.
The crowd cheered. There was no way to control
it. When you zoom out, I don't see how America
was served by this event. I don't see how voters
were served. And the way I'd characterize it in
sum total is Kaitlan Collins did the best job she
could by herself. On stage in front of a crowd of
Trump sycophants. But the situation made it
an impossibility. It was doomed to fail. And
after the break, we'll look at the reaction from
some in the media and some in elected office.